we recorded parts of this broadcast in
the days leading up to the holidays
right now let's head to the newsroom
to check this morning's headlines good
morning
and happy new year i'm adriana diaz
people around the world
ushered in the new year with skilled
down celebrations and hopes for better
times in 2021.
las vegas had some fireworks at midnight
but for the first time in years there
were none
along the las vegas strip elizabeth
palmer shows us how other big cities
said goodbye to 2020
under strict coronavirus restrictions
in times square 2021 kicked off the way
it always does
but kovid ruined the party instead of
the usual packed crowds
just a few dozen emergency workers were
invited to ring in the new
on the other side of the world though a
different picture
in new zealand where the virus is under
control
they partied as normal in australia
sydney staged its traditional
spectacular fireworks
but people stayed home and watched on tv
paris was subdued a little sparkle on
the eiffel tower
but streets emptied by the curfew
in london where there's a serious
coveted outbreak small groups gathered
along the thames
hoping for fireworks but got mounted
police
who moved along
and finally in china state tv broadcast
a dance
tribute to emergency care workers
while in wuhan covid ground zero
crowds welcomed what the whole world
craves
a happy and above all healthy new year
elizabeth palmer cbs news london